[Music]
in the wacky world of infomercials there
is one man that is the most famous face
in the industry
it's oxiclean it gets the tough tough
stains out kaboom this is the turbo
scrub the rechargeable cordless power
scrubber
then of course there's the incredible
sticky buddy it's slippy when it's wet
and it's sticky when it's dry
[Music]
hi anthony sullivan here for the sticky
buddy i am a pitch man by trade look at
that it cuts right through this soft
skin tomato i'm so excited i'm getting
out of breath a pitch man just excels at
being able to sell
certain products where is the oxiclean
shirt this
is the magic shirt it's like putting on
superman's cape oxiclean gets the tough
stains out there's anything in my teeth
looks good
i started off selling when i was 22 at a
street market in england and one day i
turned on the television and i saw my
first infomercial and a light bulb went
off in my head i thought i need to get
in front of the tv camera and get off
the street oh and put it down
you missed a spot
some of the products that we've sold
over the years are the swivel sweeper
the turbo scrub the sticky buddy
oxiclean orange glow this hurricane spin
mop clever cam um the list is endless it
has quad brush technology forwards
backwards or side to side and the worst
part is we didn't charge the battery i
think one of the most common questions i
ever get asked is does it really work as
good as it works which i think is one of
the reasons why people are attracted to
as seen on tv because you're like you
got to see this product you see what it
does it does everything clean your
toilet or clean your car or clean your
washing machine or clean your floors
it'll clean this clean that i love it
when i can do a wow demo that people sit
at home and go oh my god look at that
really works it's the power of air it's
been a struggle i haven't had the wind
behind me the whole way but it's been an
amazing journey and i continue to really
really enjoy what i do i'm never doing
that again
[Music]
you